please welcome educator and buffalo
bill's fun addict who's
probably feeling a little bummed out
today justin and chelsea flat hi
guys
[Applause]
man so close to the super bowl i know
right how are you guys feeling today a
little rough this morning after
you know sunday's game but i bet you
know it's been so long since you had
been that close
did you think you were did you feel in
your in your bones you were going to
make it this year
you know with josh allen i feel like
we're going to win every game so i
thought we had a great chance and
those guys the bills had an amazing
season and
in reality we are so thankful that you
know what they've done for our city
what they've done for our area you know
we've had season tickets for many many
years
but because of covid this year governor
cuomo didn't allow us to go to
any in-person games this year but he
allowed
fans to go to the playoff game so i was
uh
fortunate to be able to buy tickets to
the first playoff game
okay so it's the best season ever for
you right in 25 years there's no tickets
available then suddenly you can get
tickets
you get them your team's on fire but
then what happened
well 12 hours before game time
we actually were able to welcome in our
firstborn child we had a baby boy
[Applause]
and yeah so we missed the game but for a
good reason and we actually can
introduce him to you
oh please it's gerald why did you name
him fitzgerald that's the most fabulous
name
i know we uh my wife's uh my wife's an
english teacher and
i teach social studies my wife is
obsessed with the great gatsby
um i think she's just obsessed with
leonardo gabriel but
and the great gatsby is named after the
author is
f scott fitzgerald so he's fitzgerald a
little fitsy
fit seems the best reason ever to miss
the big game don't you think
i know oh my goodness oh fitzgerald
welcome to the world
um you know we actually made him a
little onesie i hope that's okay
so cute thanks drew it's the cutest
thing it came out so
wonderful but much more importantly
um is that um josh allen of the buffalo
bills heard that you guys had a good
reason for missing the game so he wanted
to say a little something to you
take a look justin and chelsea what's up
this is josh allen
i understand that he has been bill's
fans and season ticket holders for a
while now and
due to some circumstances you guys
weren't able to go to the game
but a congratulations are in order
congrats to you guys for having a child
um you know we really appreciate the
support go bills
how about that yes i know
it's amazing you grew up going to the
games and
living right by the stadium and that
you're still die hard fans and we just
wanted to
bring the bills to you thank you so much
you know josh has been an amazing he's
done a lot for
not just the bills as the team but him
you know donating a bunch of money to
the children's hospital where i was born
um through his grandmother's name
and it's just you know what he's done
for the whole community
has been absolutely amazing so thank you
josh uh from the bottom of my heart
love you go bills we're gonna have a
great year and actually you had a great
year this year yeah
and now you can carry on the tradition
with little fitzgerald go go
[Music]
yes
you